توصل القوات الفرنسيه مناورات وصفتها
بانها واسعه النطاق وغير مسبوقه في كامل
الجنوب الفرنسي وتستمر حتى الحادي عشر من
مارس اذار المقبل هذه المناورات تحاكي
اشتباكات كبيره
وتدخلا في بلد وهمي وقد جرت تعبئه السبعه
الاف جندي من مختلف القطاعات العسكريه
البريه والجويه والبحريه للمشاركه فيها
ومعنى الان من باريس مراسلنا حافظ مربح
حافظ اذا حدثنا عن اهميه هذه المناورات
لماذا تجرى
ومتى بالضبط تم التخطيط لها
نعم في الحقيقه هذه العمليه في هي وصفت
اولا بانها المناورات الاكبر منذ 30 عاما
تقريبا في تاريخ الجيش الفرنسي سيشارك
فيها اكثر من سبعه الاف جندي وعسكري وهي
في الحقيقه محاوله من الجيش الفرنسي
لاظهار قدراته من جهه ولكن ايضا لتدريب
قواته على عمليات واسعه النطاق مثل عمليه
اوريو 2023 التي ستنقسم الى مراحل هذه
المرحله الاولى منها وستليها مراحل اخرى
في الربيع المقبل هذه العمليه هي تحاكي
عمليه انزال وهمي في بلد وهمي قريب من
دوله اخرى كبرى كما قال الجيش الفرنسي
وبعد ذلك يقوم الجيش الفرنسي بمحاوله
تحرير هذه المناطق الحدوديه بين البلدين
هنالك اشتباكات وهنالك ايضا قلق الامنيه
في هذه المنطقه والجيش خلال هذه المناوره
يحاول السيطره على الوضع من خلال من خلال
استخدام الطائرات الطائرات بدون طيار
المشاه وعمليات انزال جوي وحتى البارجات
الحربيه تشارك في هذه المناورات على
ابرزها بارجه
حمل
للطائرات هنالك ايضا تعاون دولي ثمه جنود
من كل من اسبانيا بريطانيا وحتى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يشاركون في هذه
المناورات وهي كما قلت تحاكي عمليه انزال
وهمي ودفاعا بلد وهمي يعيش تجربه اعتداء
من دوله جاره وهي دوله كبرى كثيرون هنا في
فرنسا تحدثوا عن ان هذا السيناريو يقارب
او يحاكي نوعا ما يحدث الان شرقي اوكرانيا
ولكن طبعا الجيش الفرنسي ووزاره الدفاع
الفرنسيه تقول ان هذا
وهمي يهدف الى اعداد القوات الفرنسيه
للتعامل مع مثل هذه العمليات والسيطره على
مثل هذه المشاكل والقناخل الامنيه التي
يمكن ان تحدث بطبيعه حجم هذه المناورات
واتساع النطاقها حيث ستشمل اربعه عشر
منطقه في فرنسا تقريبا ستتم على اراضيها
او بحرها او حتى سمائها هذه المناورات
يشير الى ان فرنسا تريد اظهار قوتها
العسكريه من جهه بالنظر الى عده تحديات
امنيه وعسكريه راهنه على ابرزها الحرب
الان الروسيه على اوكرانيا التي يقول ليس
فقط الاوكرانيون ولكن ايضا عده قاده
اوروبيين ان روسيا قد لا تتوقف عند حدود
اوكرانيا اذا لم يتم التصدي لها هناك وقد
تقوم بعمليه مماثله في دول جوار اخرى يقول
مراقبون ومحللون عسكريون هنا في فرنسا ان
هذه من دوافع تنظيم هذه العمليه العسكريه
ولكن طبعا وزاره الدفاع تؤكد انها دائما
ما تعمل على ابقاء جيشها في حاله استعداد
وجاهزيه للتعامل مع اي طوارئ وان مثل هذه
العمليات ومثل هذه التدريبات هي امر
روتيني وعدي بالنسبه لاي شيء في العالم
نعم شكرا جزيلا على هذه المعلومات حافظ
مربح من باريس شكرا